so i think the first thing people want
to know is how often is it actually you
on set wearing the armor doing all the
stuff
what can you say
uh
let's i mean the only time it's not is
when there's massive stunt sequences uh
and obviously when they hook somebody up
to wires and they don't want them you
know me to get hurt
they they throw somebody else in uh
there was also times you know because of
the demands of the role and i'm in
almost every scene um there was times
where we would have three chiefs on
different sets around the lot uh so i
would be somewhere doing a you know
dramatic scene with the helmet off and
then justin howell my incredibly capable
stunt guy would be hooked up to ropes
somewhere doing flips and aerials and
then
you know we'd have a
second stunt guy doing some running shot
or something like that so that was that
was really when we were um you know
block shooting all the action stuff and
things were getting very busy and very
hectic uh there were times that there
were uh up to three chiefs walking
around the set because the show has been
greenlit for season two
i think everyone wants to know when are
you actually going to start filming
season 2 because i'm sure they're going
to want to see it as soon as they can
yep we'll be filming again this summer
um so we're still figuring out exactly
what the start date is but we will be
in production by summertime because we
have a hard
date that we need to be uh up and
running in order to
get some
location that is weather affected sure
so here's something you've been working
for a while yeah what was it actually
like when they call you and say we want
you to play master chief you know
because it's the lead it's the role yep
it's surreal you know
i've been around for a long time
as you as you stated um and been really
fortunate and lucky with the the
characters that i have gotten to do and
work on i
i feel really really fortunate with the
collaborators i've been able to work
with but this is this is sort of a
career moment right it's an opportunity
my first opportunity to play the lead of
a show um and that comes with with a lot
of responsibilities first of all in just
how you interact on set and the tone
that you set uh with crew and with the
rest of the cast
and then you just want it to be as good
as it can be and so that's really you
know where
where
i make my bread and butter is is just
working as hard as i can every day to
elevate the experience to the thing
bring it to the place that i want it to
be at uh and and we're working harder
and harder every single day that i'm
involved with this show to make it
the show that i think we all want to
make uh talk a little bit about finding
master chief's voice and john's voice
because i would imagine as john
progresses and finds more of his
humanity perhaps his voice and the way
he acts might change sure well um you
know you have obviously
the video game laura establishes a
character who's in his suit of meal
under armor he's always got his helmet
on so that's the only chief we know from
the games and that chief was was played
and established by an incredibly um
capable and talented voice actor named
steve downs who's you know been the
voice of the chief for the past 20 years
and he's amazing and everything he's
done um i'm i'm a huge fan of
this obviously is is my interpretation
of the character and and my chief and
the only reason to make a show you know
about the master chief and about halo is
to
get underneath the suit break down the
character and investigate aspects of his
humanity and what makes him tick the
effects of war on the soldier in our
society is one of the major themes that
we're we're looking at and him
discovering you know we meet a character
who's cut off from his humanity who
doesn't doesn't have access to his
emotions who doesn't even have memories
of his childhood and it starts there and
he has an interaction with an artifact
that brings back some memories uh from
his childhood and he begins the process
of uncovering his own personal history
so
um things you know he how he interacts
with people when he's in his suit uh is
obviously one thing um because he's he's
a super soldier he's humanity's last
hope um he has a history of of carrying
the world on his shoulders but there's
also a human being inside there who
is beginning to realize what that means
as the course of the season goes on
and so how he relates to that donning
his own dawning humanity
will be distinct from how he relates to
the world inside that
massive hunk of metal slash plastic
right exactly keyword is plastic um on
that note i already got to go i'm just
gonna say man congrats and i really
can't wait to watch episode three and
beyond